yay thank you very much indeed for
joining Piers Morgan uncensored my first
question for you I guess is an obvious
one what do you hope to achieve from our
conversation
uh that right there being uncensored
in American Media it's very censored
it's it feels like an episode of Black
Mirror a lot of times so I've put myself
across the line the point the point of
no return saying hey I know they're
going to say whatever they want about me
when I bring up the truth they're gonna
say you didn't get enough sleep it's
because of your health they're going to
call me names for my truth but these
experiences that I'm telling you about
are factually things that I've went
through and things that I refuse to keep
going through and things that I'm not
going to let my children go through and
things that I'm not going to let my
peers go through no pun intended well
look we are most certainly uncensored on
this show yeah and I want to give you
the time and the platform to really
explain yourself because I think that
sometimes sound bites about people uh
perhaps taken out of context sometimes
can create a very distort view of what a
person really thinks what do you think
looking back over the last few weeks in
particular what do you think have been
the biggest misconceptions about you
well I think there's a left agenda to
silence anyone that goes against the
agenda let's go back to Trump running
for office
back in 2015 everyone that was around me
in my industry in the entertainment
industry told me that my life would be
over I would be on the wrong side of
History I've even had threats to my life
for wearing the Trump hat and it even
ended up in you know destroying my
family and also making it where I have
to raise my children differently because
I actually am
uh a person that's classified as black
you know I classify myself as Jew
but a person has classified that had
been given that title in America as
black in America that I'm supposed to
stay in a block of a vote you never
heard the term white vote so why is
there a term black vote how is that okay
it sounds just as racist as a black
drinking fountain and I'm my dad you
know called me he said you know the
thing that the left
fear about yay or makes me the most
dangerous is I'm rich
and that's the point Tupac told me back
in the days you know you got to get your
money right and then you go to war so
I'm going to war you know I don't I
don't have I don't have endless
resources I only have like maybe you
know honestly only maybe 120 million
dollars in my account but what I'm not
gonna let happen is I'm not going to let
my kids take over Yeezy someday and have
a boardroom telling them what to do and
talking behind their back I'm not going
to let that happen to my children so I
have to fight right now and the other
powerful icons in black music when they
are at the top of the game they didn't
fight at that point they were too afraid
of losing whatever they had so by the
time they wanted to make a difference by
the time Bill Cosby wanted to buy NBC he
didn't have the Cosby Show at that time
to be able to stand up when they wanted
to literally throw him in jail you know
where they actually did throw him in
jail so people have to understand just
The Bravery there's so many people
everywhere I know everyone can relate to
being afraid to say what you're going to
feel because you feel like you're gonna
you know you're gonna lose something so
whether you agree with me or not
I believe people are going to feel the
fact that someone is brave enough to say
something every day I do five things
that people have been historically
killed for and every day and it's just
yo I want to prove first of all I am Jew
also the 12 lost tribes of Hebrew do the
math
do your research on it we have got our
culture ripped from us and then told we
were just simply void of color which is
another definition for black
but if we knew we were a culture and
knew we were a people the way the Jewish
people know then we wouldn't abort
ourselves we wouldn't shoot each other
dead in the streets and then rap about
it we wouldn't brag about you know
having sex with each other's wives we
would keep our families together and we
would do business together the most
dangerous person for a most dangerous
place for a black person in America is
actually in our mother's stomachs
because 50 percent of black deaths a
year in America is abortion
currently
I mean I can keep going but I want to
make it hey boom
I don't want to jump in too much because
I here's what I honestly think I think
you have an extraordinary mind you have
a number of extraordinary talents you're
a musical genius you're a fascinating
public figure uh what has been
interesting to me is to watch the fury
which has erupted in the last few weeks
over a series of statements that you've
made which of course as you know a lot
of offense and I guess before I get into
them I'm just curious as to
whether you think there is a line for
free speech I listen I completely agree
with you that there is a war against
free speech that people are you know
treading on eggshells all the time
terrified of expressing honestly held
opinions in case they get canceled I
think we're living in a really Insidious
era where Liberals are behaving like
fascists so on that you have absolutely
my agreement but my question for you is
do you believe there are limits to free
speech and if they are what are they
there are no limits to free speech it's
all context right Tarantino can write a
movie about slavery where actually him
and Jamie they got the idea from me
because the idea for Django I pitched to
Jamie Foxx and Quentin Tarantino as the
video for gold digger uh and then
Tarantino turned into a film
but in that film he puts a contact he he
creates a context where Leonardo
DiCaprio is allowed to use the word most
multiple times within that context so
Hollywood's job is to frame things and
they allow what context what what
content is accepted and what's not we
have our thoughts that you know everyone
has thoughts and ideas and then people
try to manipulate your thoughts and
ideas in order for Humanity to move
forward we have to be free to think and
then to actualize I like the word
actualized better than execute if you
think about executes the negative
negative word actualized to be more
positive except for the fact that has
the word act in it and everyone's an
actor especially in Hollywood I mean as
I'm like top five writers in human exist
in human history so I really get into
the way the Power of Words and I feel
very akin to Capote
Freud
Nikolai Tesla Da Vinci Matisse more
Matisse than Picasso more African cubism
than Matisse
so I just do that I thought that's kind
of for the Liberals and that's the funny
thing it's like uh liberals
when you say you're more when you say
you're more matistan Picasso as somebody
who's a fan of Matisse and Picasso
she'll spend a lot of time in in Santa
Bay where they all used to paint
together
um why do you say a Matisse what is it
about Matisse that you feel an affinity
with
I think I feel like Drake is more
Picasso and yay is more Matisse when we
talked about
and when me and Drake went to do the
show last year uh for a prison reform
and to bring awareness to the uh
incarceration of Larry Hoover I sent him
articles about the relationship of
Matisse and Picasso and the need for
these people you you need to have that
you know I need to go into the bar
and go to Starbucks that's a you know
that's a form of a modern day bar right
and just hear Drake's song playing back
to back and Drake needs to go into that
same Starbucks just in a different city
and see people wearing Yeezys
and it puts us both back into the studio
and you know God sets up these almost
similar characters these doppelgangers
it makes me it makes me really realize
God has a sense of humor like why is uh
John Gagliano and Marc Jacobs the exact
same human being just just place in a
different place or why uh does God have
it where Bernard Arnold cannot purchase
Gucci not even through the Chinese
market God does this to remind us that
we are not God because when you take
people like Elon Musk and Bernard Arno
and uh Trump or uh Jack ma uh Putin you
take these people in their own space in
their own environments you know we can
start to feel like God's on Earth but we
are nothing in comparison to God and we
are here actually to love one another
and to to collaborate and to make the
world a better place there's you know
one percent of the world are placed in
power and 99 of the world are the
audience so that one percent of the
world this idea of the United Nations
this is the world that needs to come
together this is the world that I mean
here's the obvious go-to Biden doesn't
listen to Elon Musk
the president of the United States does
not have meetings with Elon Musk that is
hey here come come come get me that's
[ __ ]
I know I'm not supposed to say that
Biden but that's [ __ ] Biden and and
I've you know it's
um
and obviously because I've been deemed
with mental health all this I have the
right to use whatever words that I like
to use well that's interesting so
somebody ask another question well yeah
let me ask you on that so you just you
just said something very inflammatory
about President Biden it will as you
know offend a lot of people and it will
particularly offend people who work in
mental health you say you should not use
a word like [ __ ] but you say that
because you yourself have had mental
health issues that entitles you to use
that kind of word as an insult now I
would say that's an arguable Point I've
had my issue my issue is I've had mental
health allegations
so do you believe that you have any form
of mental illness
I believe that I suffered from
exhaustion
I believe that I suffered from
exhaustion I suffered from being lied to
constantly by the people around me and I
believe those things can drive anyone to
a point of Maximum exhaustion
but I also believe that I'm extremely
brilliant and I'm here to make the world
a better place and I'm tired of the left
media trying to pick on me
and y'all picked on me enough and y'all
y'all finally touched the person
that's not going to stand that's not
going to take it anymore
and that's part of the reason why I'm on
uncensored because what they'd like is
for me to be quiet interesting thing
about racism and cancer culture is kind
of similar right
it racism
works on itself I can go into the Gucci
store age 18 and I just assume that
people think that I'm about to steal so
I buy more things with cancer culture
when I brought Marilyn Manson on stage
with me when he was dealing with
allegations my stepbrother Marilyn was
canceling herself within so many people
comment on my white lives matter t-shirt
there's people who are saying right
there in Fashion Week when are you going
home I'm so afraid people thought I was
going to cancel myself I'm not going to
cancel myself I'm going to keep on
delivering what I feel because guess
what it's very split opinions by the way
if I talk to a black person that makes
under a million dollars a year they
really are they really relate to the
George Floyd comments and feel hurt that
I would even
uh bring it up and question the approach
they have multiple documentaries on the
death of JFK but we're just supposed to
believe this one media Outlet version
that prayed on our trauma and our pain
and then if I talk to Rich black people
uh or white people Jew or Catholic or
atheists they're really into the Jewish
media com uh comment because it affects
their business interests okay well it
was really interesting let me just pick
you up on the two things you've
mentioned the first one is what you said
about George Floyd and the reality of
that it's not a media interpretation of
how he died because the Hennepin County
chief medical examiner concluded that
Floyd died from cardiopulmonary arrest
his heart stopped Complicated by the way
the police restrained him and compressed
his neck now he also said there were
other contributing conditions let me
finish there were other contributing
conditions narrowed arteries high blood
pressure and Fentanyl intoxication but
although these were significant
conditions he said and things that
played a role in the death they didn't
directly cause the death the cause of
death was what that policeman did with
his name
well why would a coroner lie what makes
you believe that why would the current a
lie because he could get paid to lie
because he could get paid to Lobby yeah
I watched it I watched it the majority
of the press right but I watched it for
eight minutes now tell me this have you
seen the the Candace Owens BLM
documentary I have watched uh some of
that documentary but here's what I would
say to you when you watch that video of
George Floyd no it's not a butt it's not
it's that I'm not going to watch I I
know I know what you said
I'm gonna finish
I know what it means
be quiet and let me finish Bobby you did
interrupt my question so with the BLM no
I wasn't I wasn't finished your present
agenda you haven't seen the whole thing
so we can have 20 different perspectives
on how JFK died but us as black people
not only are can we only vote one way
we're not allowed to have any other
perspectives and that the area for
George Floyd where he passed the murder
rate is up 50 percent and nothing this
is so-called movement but it didn't move
blacks anywhere right now listen a young
person I will say there are legitimate
questions about the black lives matter
movement no question but on the specific
point about how George Floyd died I
don't think it's in question about what
actually killed him it was that police
officer with his name what it is in
question it isn't it is in question I'm
questioning
person what you're questioning is it hey
are do you do you have friends that were
killed by police officers do you have
friends that were locked up do you have
friends do you have uh people aborting
half your race no so I am the black
person with the black experience that's
worth 11 billion dollars and is the most
influential person on the planet and I
am questioning it okay you will have a
right to question absolutely you can't
tell me you can't tell me you can't tell
me with your accent that me as an
American Jew black person that I cannot
question that deaf and question the
means he had I'm not I was put on camera
traumatized I'm not feeling
I mean so let me finish okay I'm not
finished talking so we can't I cannot I
see because you distract my thoughts and
then you try to make me look like a
crazy person and you feel you have the
right to cut me off and I've proven you
you guys don't want it with me this is
like Terminator 20. you've never seen
this before you've never seen this
before so I want no one to play with me
I have the right to question because
that videotape was used to traumatize my
people and force us into the Democratic
vote hey George Soros you're a real
competitor I respect you I'm worth more
money than you and I have more influence
in you and have you know Pierce Morgan
from a different country saying well the
uh I'm not going to do an English accent
because that would be racist uh I'm
funny by the way uh fine you can do that
that's what I said to you the show is
uncensored yet you can say what the hell
you like right but that doesn't mean I
can't pick you up on a few things right
you accept that
I accept that but you tried to say it is
unquestionable because this one Dr faucy
said this I know it wasn't Dr faucy but
I'm just giving an example where we hear
from even Google like people feel like
you know if you Google it it's factual
there's so much non-factual information
about me on Google but then I still
believe Google and people pay to get
certain information to the top of Google
but this is good this is keep going what
else you want to go with it
the civil rights lawyer Lee Merritt
responded to what you said about George
Floyd's death and said while one cannot
defame the Dead the family of George
Floyd is considering suit which they're
now doing as you know they're suing you
for 250 million dollars for yay's full
statements about the manner of his death
claiming Floyd died from fentanyl not
the brutality established criminally and
civilly undermines and diminishes the
Floyd family's fight so what is your
response to that
will anybody who loses a loved one my
heart goes out to them any race my heart
goes out to the pain of that I have a
theory about it now this is not a fact
this is a feeling that I have in the
documentary George Floyd's two roommates
said that George kept saying they want a
tall guy like me they want a tall guy
like me so for me I'm a creative right I
can like make a dinosaur out of a femur
right so
if I'm making a dinosaur out of a femur
and I'm looking at a documentary that
says George Floyd was telling his two
roommates they want a tall guy like me
and on the day of his death he prayed
for eight minutes they said he prayed
longer than he ever prayed what do you
think me as a creative mind the
beautiful mind right the sensitive mind
what do you think I feel could have
happened in that situation all right
well honestly if I'm being honest with
you I would say that because of your
brilliant beautiful creative mind as you
put in I don't dispute that at all
you've got an extraordinary mind and I
can see that in the way that you conduct
interviews you go off on very long
tangents but they're sort of fascinating
I find it if I said listen to you I'm
not saying you don't have a right these
are like Capote
I'm just saying it's it's a way you you
conduct yourself and I think that's very
interesting well you mean it's I already
know not why why is it oh it's not
Capote level
if you sort of if you would like this to
compare you to Truman Capote I am fat I
am happy to do that yay if you want to
be known as the new Capote I'm with you
okay I'm not going to question your
talent your talent to me is completely
unquestionable right when you question
that the question about the femur to the
dinosaur no I'm going to ask you a
different situation I'm just going to
ask you this what no you're not you're
gonna you're gonna know I didn't finish
my question well hang on you can't tell
me answer my question you can't tell me
what questions to ask you you accepted
you answer my question no I said answer
my question no I'm interviewing you too
well you can't interview me it's my
interview
your Bono I'm interviewing you too see
that's the way we wrap it let me just no
no let me just let me just put this so
no no no no no no
you're trying to you no no no no no no
no
friends you're interrupting me now to it
I'm gonna get back to it all right you
can but let me ask you you haven't
answered my question here's my question
for you would you have an answer no I'm
not answer don't don't answer my don't
ask answer my question yeah I'm not
answering anything I'm going back to my
original question in a way which is
simply this I'm not saying you don't
have a right to question how George
Floyd died but given the world watch
that horrifying video of that
policeman's knee on his neck and given
that is what the coroner said caused his
death albeit he had other underlying
conditions including fentanyl
intoxication
when the family see someone like you
who's hugely influential you you're
known around the world questioning how
their loved one died they find that very
hurtful which is why they're now suing
you for it and my question for you is do
you understand the pain that sometimes
your comments can cause like this this
circumstance with George Floyd's family
now I'm going to ask you a question
again
with my imagination if you see when you
see in the documentary that George
Floyd's two roommates said he said they
want a tall guy like me they want a tall
guy like me and that he prayed extra
long on the day of his passing where do
you think that takes my beautiful mind I
think it can take you to a place where
you want to believe something which may
not be true I'm not saying it's not I'm
just saying all the evidence
answer my honest answer is I think that
they wonder that was a that was a
political collection my honest belief my
honest belief is it what do you guys do
what do you I mean people in The
Newsroom what are they doing they're
like cringing right now they're like
whoa no we never experience before no we
never experience I'm not cringing black
entertainer that won't be threatened by
the media to back down from his opinion
yeah I think you missed yourself like
you must date me for somebody who's
going to be like the others I have a
show called uncensored for a reason I'm
giving you a platform for a reason but
you're pressing an agenda no no I'm not
you're perfectly entitled to your agenda
but do you accept
you may not always be right I just I I
just called you I just called you a liar
how does that make you that's fine if
you think I'm a liar it's fine
no you're a liar you're pressing the
agenda of the pain and Trauma and Trauma
economy that is pressed on my people by
the left
actually the trauma I think that was
implemented to George Floyd was somebody
a vile white racist police officer who
need him to his death and I agree with
the coroner's findings because I don't
see any reason why the coroner would
invent that so that's my belief if you
want to challenge that and you don't
believe it that's entirely you're right
I have a question who do you think are
the biggest vowel white racist the media
you think the media is racist
what please next question please don't
ask me any [ __ ] questions
okay let me go to the the next Fury
which has been around you in the last
couple of weeks which is your attack is
that is that is that is that is that is
that is that British for theory is that
British for Theory
what's Theory bro is that British for a
theory you actually have quite a good
British accent
um let me ask you yeah if I can about
the allegations that you have made
anti-semitic comments and in particular
when you said on Instagram I'm a bit
sleepy tonight but when I wake up I'm
going Defcon 3 on Jewish people now many
people who are Jewish found that deeply
offensive they wanted to know what what
did you mean by going Defcon 3 on Jewish
people because deathcon 3 as you know is
a heightened state of awareness for
military action so what did you mean by
that what was is your chance to clarify
what you meant by Defcon 3 on Jewish
people
well thank you for allowing me to say
what I meant due to the fact that I was
blocked by Jewish people after I said
that so it wasn't actually allowed to
say what I was about to say uh but what
I was gonna say is
I was going to talk about all of the
contracts
all of the missed dealings that I dealt
with as an Entertainer being that I'm an
Entertainer I've been wronged so many
times by Jewish businessmen and the
reason why I say people if a black man
is caught in the car with drugs or a gun
and there's three other black guys in
the car with them guess what they're all
going to jail so the reason why I say
people is I want those businessmen's
wives and fathers mothers grandmothers
and kids to ask them why is yay so mad
at us because they're taking money out
of my children's mouths and putting it
into their children's mouths I'll give
you this parallel in its analogy if you
take you know I just talked to Irina
Sheikh right and if you look at a
picture of her at age 14
this person is beautiful like one of the
most beautiful beautiful people that God
has ever created right and if any man
did her wrong at a young age she would
get to the point where maybe she would
actually hate men you've heard that
terminology right so I'm in a point
where I'm frustrated I have the right to
my anger and I'm saying that people need
to fix it I'm not going to fix what I
feel until what I'm feeling is fixed
okay can I respond I'm just gonna shut
me up and say no I'm not going to shut
you up can I respond to what you just
said
my problem with what you've said I'll be
straight with you is if I as a white man
posted tomorrow on my Instagram I'm a
bit sleepy tonight but when I wake up
I'm going Defcon 3 on black people
what would you think do you no no if I
said black people what would you think
if that was what I posted what did you
accept that black people you accepted
that black people are Jews
I'll come to that in a moment on the
specific note if I simply said in other
words all black people was the
implication of what I said I would get
rightly canceled I would get rightly
vilified and abused you I suspect would
be outraged by a white person saying
such a thing because you wouldn't make
any distinction about whether I was
talking about certain black business
people I'd fallen out with or whatever
you would think I was judging an entire
populace by the color of their skin You
Are by saying Jewish people on Jewish
people you're not saying Jewish
businessmen accountants whatever that
you've had a problem with you're
basically saying in that statement all
Jewish people which is why it caused
such offense and I'm curious whether you
even as you wrote those words understood
what Jewish people actually would feel
when you said that and didn't make any
uh specific references to any
individuals
maybe they would feel how all my people
have felt maybe they would feel the pain
of when a black artist looks up and
they've been completely they've
completely been raped by five Jewish
businessmen and there's multiple
accounts why does the fact that they're
Jewish have anything to do with it feel
like that but why why would you say it
just so happens they are well okay but I
wouldn't I why categorize them according
to their religious Faith their ethnicity
why would do that why can't you just
describe them as business people that
you've dealt with
that's fine but what you're doing by
saying Jewish people these constant
tiradesier against Jewish people
when did people find that because pirate
that sounds like you have it I think
it's a Time where's the tirade that was
just that was a tweet it was a tweet um
you asked me to explain it and that have
you felt my pain yet you haven't felt my
pain I've you don't want to feel myself
I know you don't hold a counter la la la
la la la la you don't hold
accountability to my pain you're being a
Karen I'm talking about I'm talking to
the pain I'm not a Karen I'm not going
to cancel you and I'm not gonna uncens
you I'm simply going to challenge you on
what you're saying I think you don't
understand the pain that you've been
causing with some of these comments and
I think that one in particular I can
understand God God
forbid God forbid one comment could
cause people to feel any of the pain
that my people have went through for
years even like the blacks being ushered
to the left during the Civil Rights
Movement no one is cared okay
no no all right no one is can I I mean
say I agree that the racism against
black people has been utterly deplorable
shameful unacceptable and thank God the
world is beginning to move to a better
place about the way
people like you however however one form
of racism
doesn't justify I'm not cutting you off
I'm finishing my sentence so you can
respond once before racism
racism it is racism when you say I'm
going down
that's racism no it's not I thought I
thought I thought you I thought you had
I thought you had a a platform where I
could explain how I felt you don't care
about how I feel you just want to shut
me up you don't want me to say out loud
what my people have been going through I
do
or do I do I'm very happy so what if my
people have been going through what what
led me to that point
is me a person a successful a successful
influential extremely extremely
extremely attractive person to get to
that point
I am not doubting for a moment that you
will feel genuine pain about the racism
against you and other black people in
America not for one second
would I deny that racism by who by
anybody I think racism of racism is
wrong any form of racism is wrong I
don't I I didn't say I didn't say Defcon
or anybody though you said Defcon 3 on
Jewish people specifically Jewish people
you didn't say any particular Jewish
person you said basically all of them
that is racism yay and I think if you
were honest with yourself give them the
Fallout from this you would think again
about how you phrase that sentence
because actually you didn't mean all
Jewish people you didn't fall out
given the Fallout in the Fallout do you
care about the hurt because Jewish
people fall out well you were removed
from where is that you were removed from
social media I I
always said you're not allowing me to
talk Chris okay Chris
Oh I thought it was the same person
he's American I'm British
the
um
so the thing is I want to bring joy to
the world I'm a composer right and this
is a symphony our life is a symphony we
have so many beautiful ideas but I feel
the anti-semite has been a wall a cloak
that allows Jewish businessmen boom I'll
only be the police officer that says hey
this guy with the gun is the only person
going to jail I'll be the first person
that does that in history right so look
no one else in this car riding with the
guy with the gun and the drugs is going
to jail are you happy I play by rules
that are not played by for my people
just for the sake of this I don't want
you playing by anything that makes you
happy right I don't want I don't want
you to say anything just to make me
happy that's what colonizers do is give
us rules I'm not trying to colonize
you I'm not trying to sense you all I'm
saying to you is when you use the phrase
yay like I'm going Defcon 3 on Jewish
people did you hear what I just said
though yes I did we're past that we're
past that in a conversation we're not
positive did you hear what I just said
we're not we're not past it unless I
said our Focus let me explain one are
you happy that I said I know I heard
when you do brother why are you talking
over yeah let me let me respond yay
Chris I'm Chris let's respond let me
respond right I'm simply saying what
you've just said is not what you said on
your Instagram post and you know it
right if you have a problem with
particular businessmen what do you
happen to be Jewish that is a concern
for you and you know it so you talk
about it all Jewish brother can we
brother do you what is the point brother
do you want me to grow from the
statement I just told you okay I was in
a position where I've been hurt and this
is the way I had the right to express
myself the point of this interview is
for you to question me and then for me
to answer and say okay even though the
same rules and not apply to my people if
a person with a gun or drugs is pulled
over and has four three other people in
the car they're all going to jail I'm
not going to apply that to Jewish people
for the sake of this conversation isn't
that what you wanted but you know what
you did you tried the Civil Rights me
you tried to pull me back to a week ago
but we're here today there's been plenty
of Commerce conversations of commentary
since that but you want me to go back to
1960.7 days ago let me jump in here's
what I want you to do I want you to do
okay so have we grown
yes here's how we grow I want you to
reflect have we grown I'm not in charge
of my growth you're not in charge
okay like this I'm about to suggest to
you how you may grow if you choose to
grow this way and you can you can ignore
me you can ignore me Pierce Pierce how
much money are you worth not as much as
you sadly
exactly so take my advice maybe you'll
get richer I would love to take your
business why would I listen to you why
do you why do you hear what my advice is
and then work out if I'm wrong can we do
that deal you haven't given me any
credit or a moment of reflection for the
comparison that I made the brilliant if
I do say so myself comparison that I
made to the cops pulling over one black
person and locking up you understand
what you're saying my tweet having
issues I wasted I wasn't done with the
sentence
my tweet referring to all Jewish people
I said for the sake of this conversation
I will refer to the business people who
have destroyed me and my people and my
fellow creatives but you didn't even
accept that I gave you that you tried to
push me back into 1960. no one tried to
push me back into last week no I didn't
okay if you accept that example that I
gave you I understand completely the
example you gave me I think all racism
is wrong I just will that we've grown I
would like you to reflect a few years
we've grown if you feel if you've now
changed what you wanted to say
originally my question for you is do you
now regret saying
on Jewish people are you sorry you said
that
no nothing it matters you should be
absolutely not you should be absolutely
not yeah but yeah you should be
absolutely not are the are the people
the Jewish businessmen that led me to
that place are they sorry for the way
they've raped me I don't know who you're
talking about in particular but I don't
know why you keep having to say it what
is the fact that Jewish got to do with
anything why do you keep what do you
mean they're the Jewish businessmen that
did that because business people that's
what they do why do you keep saying
Jewish business people why do you keep
using their religion their ethnicity why
they keep doing that let me update it
then okay okay so I'll say this would it
be would would I have grown into the box
you want me to go on if I say to specify
the business people that have raped my
people that just so happen to be Jewish
I think what by doing what you've just
done I find that I'm not even Jewish and
I find that offensive why do you keep
having to do that I don't think you get
it at all I know you understand the
offense you're causing when you keep
using their religious background their
ethnicity so what does a stick to beat
them with why would you do that
so what are you more concerned about
getting the richest black man of all
time the cow tell because it's not going
to happen I don't want you to count so
you can do what the hell you like you're
yay you're you know billionaire you can
do whatever the hell you want I'm just
I'm just saying to you that I don't
think you quite understand when you talk
about uh okay can I finish it's not uh
multi multi you're a multi-billionaire
okay well congratulations but that
doesn't change the fact that when you
insult the Jewish people and say you're
going Defcon 3 on the Jewish people that
is as racist as anything you say you've
been through and any pain that you've
experienced it's the same thing racism
is racism
and you know that I think don't you
yeah obviously that's why I said it
so you said it knowing it's racist
yes I fought fire with fire okay I'm not
here to get holes down at least that's a
different type of freedom fighter that's
honest all right you were racist because
you knew it was racist but you decided
to do that because people have been
racist to you is that is that your
position no I'm not I first of all I
can't what is the beginning read the
whole tweet
I'm sure you have it in front of it
somebody in your office has it get him a
coffee and a yay tweet
what do you want to know the whole tweet
I want you to read it out loud sir I'm a
bit sleepy tonight but when I wake up
I'm going Defcon 3 on Jewish people the
funny thing is I actually can't be
anti-semitic because black people are
actually Jew also you guys are toy with
me and tried to blackball anyone who
opposes your agenda that was the exact
tweet
I like reading that whole thing I can't
be anti-semite I love Jewish people I
work with Jewish people yo watch this
watch this some of my best friends are
Jewish right so you know how that how
many times have you heard that statement
of course of course wait wait I've have
we ever heard that term before some of
my but the funny thing is they are I
work with Dove Charney that got kicked
out of his company out of American
Apparel I work with this guy every day
he's like my twin he's one of my
favorite people and the planet and we
work through that we talked through and
he says yay why are you so mad and I'm
like this is why I'm mad this contract
right here what's gonna happen before
I'm done we're going to open up all of
the music industry contracts all of the
publishing deals all of the athlete
deals all of the acting deals all of the
mortgages all of the deals but that's
fine but yeah that's the business people
who we went at that's all fun you can do
it but it has to start somewhere of
course you can do all that and when you
do that it has to start somewhere I hope
you won't be judged as a black business
person doing it all the time that people
don't phrase it all the time by the
color of your skin but by your business
Acumen isn't that what you would like
isn't that what equality actually means
and of course I'll be judged by that
because when people come into power
people get judged you know what I'm
saying like there's nobody that gets
judged more than a straight white male
the straight white male has the least
amount of a platform to even speak a
straight white male can't say my wife
hurt me today because people say well
you're hurting women a straight white
male can't say hey a black employee
didn't come in to work on time because
then people will say your race is a
straight white male can't speak on a
homosexual person because they'll say
your home you're homophobic and so I
empathize with the position
of the straight white male and part of
the reason why I empathize with that
position is because I know that I'm
headed to that position and what
position that is that is top power
position okay that's the top power
position where you get all the Rocks
thrown and that's that's the thing I
have friends right that will like
you know actually that's the reason why
I'm going to be a good leader someday
because I'm really empathetic but I call
black people out on their stuff I call
white people out on their stuff because
we're all people we're actually only one
species and in order to whether it's my
friends texting me like bro you got to
get in the gym you're looking chubby in
the photo you know it's like we have to
hold
each other accountable to what's
actually happening and it's so much is
based on you did that tweet wrong so
what I will say is I feel that my words
demand more sensitivity for the
frequency that I'm operating at and that
and the amount of people that I'm
communicating to and I take that
responsibility right now but I will also
say everything happens for a reason
because if it had been perfectly worded
in English
and because there's nothing wider than
English itself right I'm already not
speaking in my mother tongue right so uh
if I had perfectly worded it and the
most sensitive way then we wouldn't be
here right now now we're opening up the
conversation like there I'm not allowed
to say whether or not I'm running for
office in 2024 but I'll tell you what if
the left let's say the left
the left would have never supported me
anyway
and now I've got to call to attention I
am who you should support the left did
not allow Trump to be president they
treated him like he wasn't even the
president so even then he won he was
losing half of the American people every
day and it divided the country what I'm
saying whoever goes into office for uh
British media for American Media we must
support our leaders and not just run
this hyper negative you know what I will
uh and black people hate when I
apologize for this when I see people
like John Legend and Chrissy Teigen talk
down on the president I'm like wow that
kind of sounds like me that kind of
sounds like the Telethon I opened up
this level of disrespect towards our
leaders and people are happy ah and the
left saw that and say well let's just
have every celebrity do what yay did at
the Telethon so I take responsibility
for that moment and you know what I just
want to give every Jewish person a big
hug also I'm envious of the Jewish
people I'm envious of how they don't
abort their children I'm envious of how
they don't shoot each other in the
streets and then rap about it I'm
envious of how their their families stay
together I'm envious that they turn
their phones off on Friday night and the
family comes together I'm envious of how
they do the business together and I want
that for the darker Jews I want that for
the black people I want that we need
that God said we should remove the word
want right we're going to have that and
this is the beginning of it but it seems
to me and correct me if I'm wrong but it
seems to me that you are acknowledging
as you've just acknowledged that it was
wrong to say what you said about
President Bush when he doesn't care
about black people that may have
encouraged all this disrespect towards
Presidents since I think it's an
interesting point you made it does seem
to me yay talking to you that even if
it's hard for you to admit this that you
do regret the wording of that tweet
which caused all the problems and you
wouldn't phrase it that way again am I
right
I would tell I would tell my dad that my
dad loved the White lives matter t-shirt
because what audacity does a black man
have to wear the exact same t-shirt that
a white man could wear you know and my
dad was a black panther I mean we have a
water purification Center you know he's
like the original Steve Jobs he's the
educated version of me right and he and
he liked both of those things but he
said
you know yay he even calls me yay now
he's like Yay if you you've got to be
more sophisticated with your wording and
that wording like I said I'm a bit
sleepy and it lacked the sophistication
needed to be the true conductor that I
am because it's the conductor's job to
bring people together and that was
divisive which is not who I want to be
right so I'll tell you that I'm not
looking and also let me let me know you
agree so don't say you agree with me
then
I want to I want to talk okay let me let
me show them I'm just thinking right now
with so my heart is the idea for people
who do actually have severe mental
health issues you know the word [ __ ]
for you know there's parents that have
children who actually are mentally ill
and that word
is really offensive right to those
people so why use it and and just
because yeah just because I was I was
feeling
um
uh
uh what's a couple reasons because
people call me [ __ ] they treat me
like I'm [ __ ] uh and so I embrace it
it's like you call somebody so much they
say I'm
you call somebody a [ __ ] so much they
say I'm a [ __ ] you call somebody a
[ __ ] somebody should say I'm
[ __ ] like I was exhausted and I
embraced the idea
of having a serious mental health uh
issue but Noah I mean not Noah Noah also
but Moses was basically on speed when he
was doing what he did
out of Interest yeah how much sleep do
you get a night
I don't I I'm not here to talk about how
much sleep I get I don't literally just
been talking about how much sleep do how
much sleep do you get in there I had
about five and a half hours last night
actually not very much
um but but you're the one that's raised
this issue and I probably had the same
right my question is that everybody had
the same but it's only because you've
been talking about you don't believe you
have a mental illness you think it's
lack of sleep so I think it's an obvious
question to ask well how much sleep do
you get do you are you constantly sleep
deprived is that is that one of the
reasons perhaps sometimes as you say you
feel sleepy and you shoot from the hip
verbally and you say stuff that maybe
when you're rested you wouldn't say it
the same way would that be fair tell me
what's
okay no it's not fair because what's
more important
the pain and the truth of what I'm
talking about and what led me to that
tweet or the Tweet itself
I think both can be true because the
problem you have is I think you've
acknowledged one tweet I think you've
acknowledged the words
yes I understand but you know the damage
it caused and I think I understand that
that was offensive and I think that you
have accepted
no near no no you as a white person are
so stuck on the idea that what I said
was offensive which is a very caring
approach you're not sticking on the fact
you you have not unpacked what happened
with those contracts I've said that but
you didn't ask me another question about
it that means there's an agenda
absolutely I have repeatedly said to you
that I'm sure I I do not disbelieve that
you've had contract business issues with
various managers accountants and so on
my argument is that when you do with me
or other me I'm sure I'm sure many other
artists in the music business yeah of
course you know why you're sure or
because because you don't care to do the
research because it doesn't affect you
no it's because you said you've done any
research no yeah let me explain to you
I'm not doubting what you don't care I
do care you don't care about me you
don't care about my people I care about
me I care about my people so as for me
to stand up and God forbid I step on
someone's toes while I'm at it it's not
some monsters you stepped on the entire
Jewish people's toes with a very deeply
inflammatory tweet which I think you've
now accepted you shouldn't have phrase
that way it's taken a bit of time to get
there but I think you have accepted that
right
have you accepted that you've put no
effort into understanding how I got
there
I don't think I don't think honestly 10
years from now honestly I don't think
there is apologize to me about this
interview I'm not you're gonna apologize
to me about this interview within the
next 10 years no I'm not because here's
the thing my words I don't doubt you've
had it's very one-sided it's very it's
very white-sided
it's very like it's not white-sided I'm
not doubting you've had business issues
I'm saying the way to respond to that is
Jewish people millions of people
millions of people have had Defcon 3 on
their contracts right you didn't you
didn't say that you didn't say that said
millions of people well I open it up not
I didn't but now I'm saying it now okay
so now what I think you should say I
think you should say to the Jewish
people I'm sorry for the offensive
language I used in that tweet I wouldn't
do that again this is what I really
meant I think people would respect you
if you said that I don't know why you
can't just say that house let me you
know you know you know when I'll say it
when I sit down with the people who
write out the contracts for the MBA and
for the NFL and for professional music
and for uh acting contracts we need to
go to the top lawyers the top execs the
owners of the stadiums the owners of the
football teams and the owners of the
record labels and we're going to put
them all in one room and we're going to
read every let's go top 10 in each one
of these categories right let's read
Michael B Jordan why would any of us why
would any of that hey bro hey hey bro I
ain't finished I ain't finished my
sentence
has anything to do with regret hey boy
don't finish I told you
oh don't treat me like a boy then I'm
gonna finish my sentence or my idea
nothing you're saying has got anything
to do with the Tweet cool
so I was in the middle of a sentence boy
okay so are you going to allow me to
finish my sentence yes
if you then answer my question Okay so
okay so I'm gonna tell people when I
would apologize for the tweet this is
what has to happen first
I need all of the top Executives in
Hollywood I need the top Executives at
the MBA and at the NFL we'll we'll do
those two sports specifically and I want
the top Executives in music dealing with
publishing dealing with uh like Spotify
and apple music and uh Universal Music
and all the topics that uh let's do like
five topics X there and I want to look
at the top 10 earners and each one of
those fields contracts openly we want to
compare and contrast the contracts and
then once we open that conversation and
we need to do it on a platform live with
lawyers asking questions and we'll and
we'll have the top lawyers like a Johnny
Cochran Robert Kardashian leveled legal
team you know looking at all of these
contracts together after that moment
happens then I will say I'm sorry
okay if that's your position interview
adjourned love you
okay that's the end of the interview
I'm not I can't I just get the feeling
from you that you're obviously a complex
character brilliant in many ways
fascinating like I say compelling uh you
have a huge appeal to millions of people
around the world it just seems to me
that occasionally your mouth gets you
into trouble on the perhaps on
reflection sometimes you look back and
wish you hadn't said things is that
accurate
nah not really
because
the things I say are on behalf of God
like it's not always Godly because I'm a
man but God is definitely using me
you're you're uh Catholic faith all
right what's your background Catholic
yeah
well we're we're working for God here
and it's just like with black people now
with entertainment we're coming into
wealth but all the other you know black
people with anywhere near
uh my amount of wealth would never cross
the lines of you know taboos inside of
the media that I would that actually we
used to in rap all these words we used
to say these so it's all these like
words that are being removed from our
vocabulary words that evoke emotion
don't you feel like the salt is being
taken out of our our food you know look
at Dune the people who control the salt
controlled all the money and people are
trying to control the salt and it's salt
in our language that's why I'm I I will
not apologize for
uh having a bit of salt in my words I
will say hey this can be improved on but
it's like hey look I'm gonna update
you're looking at
the gods iPhone 100. we are God's iPhone
right if you think about it we're his
favorite creation we were made in His
image and we need updates and Society
capitalism media and thought police have
been stopping us from our updates we
have to have a thought and then we have
to
actualize it I like the word actualize
better than execute because it executes
a negative word we discussed this we
have to actualize there's so many think
about you know for
uh a homosexual kid
age 12 at school not wanting to say out
loud how he felt or feeling like if he
said how he felt he would get bullied or
what if he said how he felt and then
somebody said you said the way you felt
and what your experience was in the
wrong way now you need to apologize
we're fine that you felt that way but
you need to apologize for the way you
said it but just having the the courage
to do it in the first place would be you
know that's the thing that needs to be
given credit like yeah you know what
we'll say in these past two weeks I made
a big splash because the first time you
dive in the deep end you're not going to
look like an Olympic swimmer but we're
gonna have to learn how to swim and I've
dived in the deep end okay I think I
understand what you're saying let me ask
you about your family yeah lots of
speculation of course constantly if if
you understand if you understand what
I'm saying could you translate what I'm
saying yes I want you to translate what
I said and then let's move on to the
next question okay let me attempt to try
what did I mean by that I think what she
meant was that you are not afraid to
ruffle feathers you're not afraid to
cause trouble where you feel it's
Justified you're not afraid to call
people out who you think deserve to be
called out but occasionally
you've you've expressed yourself in a
way that perhaps hasn't quite hit the
right Mark and that you are work in
progress as indeed we all are and that
you could phrase things better which
would cause less offense to a wider
number of people when in fact the target
of your anger may be much more specific
that would be my interpretation of what
you've just said
do you think that we can move forward as
a civilization without there being any
offense because one person's truth can
be the other person's lie
part of me wants to say yes to that but
I do think there is a line and we should
all be mindful of the line and the line
to me is I don't think any form of
racism or perceived racism should ever
be tolerated I don't think that is free
speech it's just hate speech and I think
one of the problems with what you said
about the Jewish people was the more
generic way that you phrase that
sentence people didn't understand you
were talking about specific business
people you'd have a problem with they
thought you genuinely meant you were
going Defcon 3 on all Jewish people and
they took that to be a blatant form of
anti-Semitism I think you've explained
in this interview that was not your
intention at all which is good but I
think if you're asking me to interpret
what you've just said yourself that
would be my interpretation that you know
your your work in progress and sometimes
you say stuff I didn't just it doesn't
quite doesn't quite it doesn't quite get
over what you're really meaning
but what I really mean is I don't want
it to be settled I don't want I don't
want uh I don't want to be forgiven by
Jewish people
until we get to what the problem really
is I don't want you know like Elon he
got on Twitter he said I talked to yay
took it to heart and I liked my boy
standing up for me but I was like but my
the fight isn't done though everybody
White media left media they just want to
squash the fight they want to keep the
pain of George Floyd going right but
they don't want the pain of our
Representatives must say to you about
Jewish business out of Interest
it's vague to me right now I don't want
to misquote them what was it just say to
me what was the General point of what he
was saying
it's vague to me it's truly vague to me
you know I'm an honest person I tell you
what it was but I keep on saying it's
just always about this tweet it's so
much more if you if you look back at
this energy at this interview and it's
like a direction arrow
it's more in the direction of fixing the
statement than fixing the problem I
think that's my problem I understand but
I would say to that I think they're two
different things and you can fix both
actually uh and I I accept that part of
what you were trying to do and the point
you were trying to make I completely
understand it because you've explained
it in more detail on Elon Musk there is
a suggestion that when he gets control
of Twitter which seems likely now that
he will bring you back you'll bring
Donald Trump back you think that would
be right
it will be lit
do you think it's wrong that you and
Trump have been have been banned from
these platforms
absolutely I was talking to Trump a
couple days ago and he was like I'm not
going to do his voice right but he was
saying uh
you know I had 277 million followers and
the next day I had nothing and that
related to
you know Mark Zuckerberg meta you know
Mark Zuckerberg thinks he is the
government these tech companies feel
they're more powerful
than the US government to the point of
actually kicking the actual president of
the United States off of an American
social media platform this is the world
we live in
and I would say I listen to that I agree
with you and I'll tell you why I I think
it's completely inconsistent that
companies like Facebook and Twitter
allow people like the Ayatollah of Iran
for example to remain on the platform or
Taliban people to be on the platform but
they don't allow an American president
that seems to me completely ludicrous
yes and this is part of the 100 year
plan that they have books on about
uh you know China's takeover of America
after losing the Industrial Revolution
now let's talk about business people we
won't refer to their race and by the way
I'll tell you as a Jew person a person
that has a lot of Jewish friends it's
not a race it's a people right and every
Jewish every Jewish homeboy I know is
going to be like yo yeah that's right so
um
uh but it's hard
to attract it's it's hard to influence
patriotism on capitalists
and it's a responsibility for us as
Americans to retake our power in Media
to retake our power in our schools to
retake our power and our Farms to retake
our power and our medicine and our
hospitals
to revitalize the country because
America invented rock and roll at the
end of the day we have the inventions
America created Apple you understand
like we created the platforms that the
world uh that the world runs on now and
we've allowed the business people in
these companies to sell us and whatever
the term is sell them in a handbag
whatever it is for cheap and Americans
are God-fearing for the most part
God-fearing Christian people and we're
not cheap and we can't be sold for cheap
and we're here to stand up
and say you gotta honor who we are our
families you got to honor our God Jesus
Christ so uh our next subject next
subject can I can I ask you something
let me ask you something else here I
want to ask you about your your family
yeah because you mentioned families
there a lot of stuff has been written
about you and your family uh a lot of it
fueled by you by Kim by others where are
things now with your family what is what
is your relationship like with Kim with
your kids
uh uh
Kim has
zionists media handlers
surrounding her all in and out her Hulu
TV show all in and out her her family
all in or out the house that I created
for my family but God is alive the Devil
is a defeated Foe and Kim is a Christian
woman and she's not here just to have
content up on adult channels she's not
here just to have that last interview
magazine cover if you look at the two
interview magazine covers look at the
one when I was there and look at the one
when I'm not there and that's the reason
why this Tuskegee experiment of such
that's happened to the black community
where they took the fathers out of the
home and the leaders out of the
community and have torn apart the
community now they've seen that's worked
and they're doing that to America
they're attempting they're trying I mean
that interviewing the interview the
interview magazine cover you're talking
about I think is the one where she was
basically semi-naked in front of the
American flag and I thought that was
pretty distasteful actually
it was about the American dream and I
thought well if that's the American
dream we're all screwed I mean in
America
and I and I agree with that and I I
didn't feel the platform to voice my
opinion because I wanna it's always like
hey this is your kid's mother this year
but it's time with the leaders like I'm
still the priest of that home Chris I'm
still the priest of that home they they
want to make it this matriarch Society
all that and you know but I am the
priest of this home and God is alive I
am the living Robert Kardashian and I'm
going to stand up for what God would
want as a Christian and then people say
as a Christian or you're not supposed to
curse you're not supposed to have
righteous indignation but I do you know
Christians had swords also Christian's
got guns I tell you that you know so but
do you talk to you talk to him I mean
there have been reports here that you
and Kim don't really talk at the moment
she's distancing herself from me because
of the stuff you've been saying was
getting controversy is that true
I mean John Legend is distant distancing
my himself from me and buying more
Christmas sweaters in the middle of
spring also so I'm not saying that you
know they're making the right decisions
uh she's being influenced you know but I
guarantee you what's not gonna happen
we're not going to see any one of them
John Legend Christmas sweaters no time
soon but do you talk to her are you
still in touch wait said don't you think
it's like don't you think it's like
funny to like make a joke out of stuff
sometimes don't you think like God has a
sense of humor gosh but watch this God
God when I got married I bought this
house I like you know what I'm saying I
did this tour and spent all the money I
had on this house to like surprise Kim
and give her this house that she wanted
that Lisa Marie Presley used to own and
um and then I got the house and then I
put all this money into renovation and
then there goes the neighborhood Drake
moves down the street five blocks and
that's when I knew God was funny but
watch this is where God is even funnier
here goes like Louis CK part two level
because Louis CK is the funniest man
alive on cancel him now right so the and
he was funnier before he's canceled
because all he would do is type of jokes
that you'd get canceled all right so uh
uh so
um I got an office
and you know outside of Crenshaw like an
opportunity Zone and this office 57 000
square foot office is the one that
Tucker Carlson came to visit me at and I
look out the window and who's all and
whose office is being built a brand new
one the skims office
is like who's writing this stuff you
know I'm saying like God is funny so
that's the thing we always got to be
like we got to be funny we got to have a
sense of humor like you know but yeah
let me ask you let me ask you there's a
lot but are you are you sad that you're
getting divorced are you sad the
relationship came to an end
that happened to you we got to do
divorce two year yeah yeah
we've been got divorce yeah I mean let
me rephrase that are you sad that you're
no longer together that you're divorced
we'll always be together
she dresses exactly like me what do you
mean like my kids are me you know
there's no person that she'll ever get
with that will influence her more than
God and then her priest on Earth which
was me you know whether it's the the
skims clothing line the designers the
The Architects all those people you got
the clintons the left
utilizing what we built together to try
to use her as an influence for the black
culture and the word culture in general
for the next elections they need those
300 million followers from Kylie and Kim
on their side going into their election
as they push trauma culture to the black
people again as they claim anything any
my questions of business dealings to be
anti-semitic comments and push you know
Kim to you know as a billionaire mother
of a lawyer and a mother of four Jew
black children
uh
uh to do covers like interview and
that's what happens when they take the
dads out the home and that's what
they've been doing in the hood they take
the fathers and the leaders out of the
homes and if we keep on allowing this to
happen and we don't have some level of a
decency Clause inside of our media on
what everyone sees like when I was young
and I would go to the video store if I
wanted to go into the adult section it
was a curtain it was a person sitting
there watching making sure that kids
didn't go in if the kids went into that
section there was a video camera and
they would have you'd be escorted out of
that section now that section is forced
through Tick Tock that section is
subverted and kind of mixed with the
drink inside of Music directed at
children inside of content through
Disney on Hulu which is Disney also and
in so many branded commercials to
confuse children and to sexualize our
children way too early yeah because they
can even make their own decisions about
their life look you make some very
interesting points again just to clarify
one thing though you are actually
divorced are you because my
understanding was that you weren't
actually divorced yet
you know I asked God the same question
some mornings
am I divorced God am I am I divorced
because I might be divorced on paper but
I'm not divorced of the idea of being
the protector of not only this person
who is so influential imagine Kim
making all of her decisions that she
does publicly you know grown folks
businesses grown folks business never
know what could happen with a little
sippy sippy or whatever but you know all
the decisions that she makes publicly
being based on an audience of one and
Pierce what audience do you think I'm
saying that is well you
no not me for us as Christians right uh
who is our audience we have an audience
of one well you mean God
God so Picture This World Envision this
world here's another one this is past my
whole this is past what I'm saying about
having the con the the heads of the
football teams and the basketball teams
in the music industry uh opening up
their contracts the way I do right
picture the most influential woman on
the planet which is Kim Kardashian right
um
and I got this one thing I want to
definitely say in the interview
um
picture the most influential person
on the planet the most influential woman
on the planet
performing in public only for that
audience of one for God imagine the
overwhelmingly positive effect that that
will have on the planet and
Mark these words it will happen someday
okay I had this thing I had this like
you know of course I'm I'm a divorced
and this is like a a funny thing I
thought being that her name is no longer
West
and my name is no longer yay if there
was ever I mean sorry being that her
name is no longer West and my name is
now only yea if we were ever to be
together again what would our name be
kimye
would you like that
everything is up to God and God
has proven to me
many times that it's not about what I
want or what I would like
it's just up
to him
on what he sees
fit but you know David I mean yeah but
do you still love the Sheep sorry not
with an S do you still love Kim
I absolutely love I love her for life
and I pray and I will protect oddly
enough I'll actually protect her because
when I call out things that I feel are
wrong you know what I'm saying when I
make products like say the difference
between me and Bernard or no
like say watch Elon Musk every product
the reason why Elon Musk is like a Steve
Jobs is
if he makes a flamethrower he would use
that flamethrower if he makes a cyber
truck he would use that cyber truck me
if I make some 3D printed boots you know
I'm gonna have the the 3D printed boots
on Wow every day can I get a pair
absolutely sir
These Boots Are a hit love yes those are
fantastic
would you like to one day sir do you
think given that you've got all these
kids together
would you like one day to get back with
Kim do you think do you feel like you've
gone through a very tumultuous period
but that actually the love Underneath It
All between two people remains and would
you like to get back together
those thirst traps still be fire
is that do you understand what I said do
you understand that language
you better explain it explain it to me
what do you think those thirst traps
still be fire means can you explain that
to me well with my uh rather rather
straps still be fire I would imagine it
means these brilliant British man I
would imagine it means you still fancy
or what your ex-wife is that right
you know I I would prefer to not be put
on this uh I would never I would prefer
to not be put
on the spot
uh on these kind of questions what I can
say is
uh God as a God is alive and
he places people he placed David in
uh
uh to tend to to God had David tend to
the Sheep knowing that one day he would
prepare him to fight Goliath
so I believe that
that day of me fighting Goliath has been
this
past two weeks the media is Goliath
and there would be no chance of having a
civil civilization or a civil
uh Democracy in America without me
challenging the media two years out from
the election
because this thing that I'm challenging
may be setting myself up to one day be
able to be president or it's uh maybe
for the other president but regardless
we have to have some decency in America
as the thought leaders and the content
that we put out but yeah
on that point you keep talking about the
media as if somehow it's the media
that's created all this Fury in the last
two weeks but you have said other things
which in my opinion the media couldn't
ignore you know you suggested in your
interview with Tucker Carlson the gap
for example the clothing wear company
had prior knowledge of the a validate
shooting which is obviously completely
insane
why would you say that and then why
would you be surprised if the media if
the media then react to it about it
what I'm saying is that was worded
that might have been worded in a way
that the media could take in the wrong
way
but I thought it was really interesting
the amount of people that Gap
we had we had a release that was
happening and the amount of people at
Gap
that were rallying around this as a
media moment if they didn't know
about that where there's theories you
can't say that the theory is about 9 11
are completely insane I see that's just
the person kind of person well look
you're perfectly entitled to have
theories I think most of them are
completely insane on this specific one
yeah on your valve day you even
suggested that Matthew McConaughey even
suggested that Matthew McConaughey may
have it was all a bit weird that he was
speaking so early about it when in fact
he came from a validate and spoke very
passionately after this atrocity
so I think people read these comments
are like what are you talking about
no okay so I'm not
what I'm saying
is
I definitely feel there is a major media
push around that to create trauma and
fear culture because the amount of
people and this is not to be in any way
I care about people who have passed away
and have lost loved ones 20 kids
in a classroom 20 children were shot
dead in school so let me explain no one
in the media is putting how many any
sort of trauma into that that is the
trauma
okay Pierce Pierce how many how often
does that happen in my hometown
well 20 kids are killed in school in one
mass shooting as far as I'm aware it's
never happened in your hometown has it
every
yeah it does and it's not in one match
shooting killed in Chicago I didn't
finish I didn't finish okay let's not do
this again okay we we reviewed you could
talk at least
at least 14 kids are killed in Chicago
every week and there's no media push
around it and that's my issue and I was
at Gap there was no media push around
the killings in Chicago
I agree with you I completely agree my
youngest son has recently been at
University of Chicago every year and
there were two students shot in that
time I completely agree that there is
never enough attention given to all the
slaughter from gun violence in Chicago
completely agree with you what I can't
agree with is any suggestion by you that
anyone at Gap or Matthew McConaughey or
anybody else had any prior knowledge of
what happened to davalde of course they
didn't
what I'm saying is I'm not saying they
did but with the amount of tension that
went understand I was jealous once again
you feel me I'm jealous that so much
attention went
in this direction but doesn't go into
the direction of Chicago then say that
say that yeah amount of people that's
what you should say yeah but it comes
down to the way you freeze it bro bro
hey hey I just said it yeah like I just
said you're not always going to say the
things the right way but at least I have
The Bravery to open the conversation
your first your first sentence isn't
your last sentence my first rap that I
told wasn't my last rap that I told and
now that's the whole point it said once
it said except that it was said I am the
iPhone 20 right I'm growing I'm a hybrid
I'm updating I'm constantly updating
that's what we're supposed to do you
can't you can't drag me back because
that's you enjoy that right when you
bring it up I'm saying hey this is what
I'm saying I
felt you know this think about this have
you ever heard the term premeditated
murder yes
I I feel I feel like
the George Floyd was a premeditated
murder that's my feeling based off of
and we never got to that in the
beginning but that's my feeling based
off of the information I saw in the
documentary I think it was a premeditary
murder in the sensitive I I agree but
not for the reason you think I think it
was premeditated in the sense that that
policeman didn't give a damn about
George Floyd's life stuck his knee on
his neck for eight minutes and killed
him so but I know we didn't agree about
that I don't want to go back at least I
want to ask you I want to ask you yeah I
think the policeman I think I think the
policeman was involved with it too but
not in the way that you think about it
right I think he was involved in a
different way I think we'll have to I
think he was also part I think he was
also part of the setup okay look we're
not going to agree about that but he's
been moved he's been moved he's he's
been he's been moved and you go I need
you to watch the documentary and we
could talk offline and then talk online
again okay because what's not fair is
for a white martyr like JFK to be
analyzed a hundred different ways but
then for a black martyr like George
Floyd for us to only accept the one way
that's like us only accepting the
library for the black vote like I said
the opportunity different ways like I
said to you you are completely entitled
to challenge anything frankly and I'm
equally entitled to come back to you and
say what I think that is a democracy is
about let me ask you before it's before
I think about you but no no I got okay
no I don't want to keep going back to
that same information right there yeah
but look at the disparagement because I
still had a I had an idea I don't like
the word point I had an idea that you
didn't Embrace right there
the Martyr JFK we analyzed his death a
hundred different ways right but what
George Floyd he died that way and then
as white people telling super brilliant
successful black people
you okay you have the right you're it's
literally like on some black lives
matter like your life matters like oh
your idea matters but then shut up and
we're not gonna go back to it no we're
gonna unfold it I need you to watch that
documentary and I want us to talk line
by line I want to do because look I
think that we're a good conversation and
now within the next two years we need to
talk a lot of times I would love to do
that this kind of thing honestly I would
honestly I honestly unpack I agree
listen yeah let me say to you I've I've
wanted to interview you for years I
genuinely mean it when I say I think
you're one of the most brilliant
talented people that I've seen in the
public sphere and you have a lot of
fascinating ideas and you're incredibly
creative and you're completely entitled
to your views uh but I'm entitled to
mine and I think we've had some really
uh really interesting exchanges actually
I want to just talk to you quickly
before we finish about your kids and
about you as a father what kind of kids
do you want than to be what kind of
values do you want to instill in your
children
I want my kids to finish their education
I know that my album was called The
College Dropout but when I look at the
way
you know just like like you said your
kids are in the University of Chicago we
need the education that's another thing
to be jealous about you know the the
Muslims have the Quran right and Jewish
people also have their uh their holy
books but they have
the education
and once we have the education the
education and we have the the strong
black uh Minds we need to pull them
together there hasn't been end-to-end
black owned communities since Black Wall
Street or since the gentrification of
Harlem like I was talking I have this
tech company called stem right that had
the most successful launch in Tech
History with the 80 000 stem players as
far as a first launch right we saw 80
000 players back in February and we went
off the Apple platform and now we're
coming with the Next Generation that has
a projector in it and it's coming with
four thousand ninety six movies I did
that because my Amiga computer had 4096
colors when I was in seventh grade and
also you can download films without
having to use an Apple product so I call
this guy and we're working on finishing
up elements of the deal and he's using
emotional bullying and like his
shoulders are down you can could tell on
the call he says well because of your
comments we're not going to be able to
hire people as the people that we need
and I said well well how many people do
we have working for us he said 60 and we
have 40 part-time I say well how many
Jewish people do we have he said well I
don't know I don't know we have some and
I said well do we have black people
working for he said yeah I said how many
he said two
and I said you're telling me we can't
find 60 black Engineers well yeah and
see that's where that comment that got
me into so much trouble forced me to
look at myself as a black as the richest
black man since Mansa Musa right with
multiple tech companies and where am I
kicking the tires inside of my own
company to ensure that I'm hiring my
people because Chinese people hire
Chinese people and Jewish people hire
Jewish people and Catholics hire
Catholics right but with blacks we'll
give our company to uh Bernard Arnold
we'll give our company to Mark
Zuckerberg we'll give our company away
and it would almost come off as
anti-semitic if I hadn't crossed that
gun line so far to say hey I'm I have to
go and ensure that I'm hiring the the
brightest black Minds to my black owned
tech company you know Kamala is our
never again we're never gonna just hand
something over just because we like the
way this person looks and we have the
emotional connection because she was a
Delta and my mom was a Delta she got 96
percent of the black female vote you
would have thought Drake was running and
we haven't seen her really honestly
since and yeah I want to say something
about the left the left you guys got to
sit with me your current Administration
that these guys put up they they [ __ ]
the pot on this one they should have got
Bernie but Bernie had too much of a
conscience and so you got a guy with no
conscience instead of getting Bernie
Sanders you guys got Weekend at Bernie's
and I I and you know that you don't like
where where we're at right now so we got
to have a conversation
disagree with you about uh I don't
disagree with you about President Biden
um uh all coming to Harris for that
matter let me ask you about someone we
haven't mentioned Vladimir Putin and
what he's been doing in Ukraine what is
your view of that
I
do not believe in war
and I believe
that there is ways that America could
have avoided
this war
but
Biden has money Biden has reasons for us
to be at War right now for selfish
reasons and what I would like to do
without giving you too much information
I would like to speak with my political
advisors to give you the exact
uh exact information I'm not gonna hey
watch this one pierce I'm not gonna
shoot from the hip on this one
especially talking about war and things
as sensitive as Ukraine and the Russian
war no no you we already got that um the
[ __ ] comment earlier that we could
work on that I feel like is going to be
massively offensive and I really do all
right now that one I do apologize to
people that offended earlier in the
interview on that comment maybe we could
look at scrubbing that if we if we if we
deem well actually actually I would say
I would say this it's an uncensored
interview you said something which
you've now wished you hadn't said and
you've apologized I actually think that
says a lot about you right that shows
you've got that ability to be self-aware
to understand when you cross the line I
think someone like you with all your
energy and creativity and your passion
you're gonna say stuff the way that you
talk constantly and in such an
extraordinary manner you're gonna trip
up you're going to say things the wrong
way I don't think there's anything wrong
and when you do that doing what you just
did and saying I'm sorry I crossed a
line I apologize it's actually quite
empowering
do you
you know what I think you know what I
think I'll go ahead and do
I feel that I've given the platform and
I think by holding the idea of an
apology hostage is not Godlike correct I
feel like we have to free
yeah you know and I think that's the
point that you've been making and
because we sat down and had this
conversation
you know
I will say I'm sorry for the people that
I heard with the Defcon the the
confusion that I call I feel like I
called I cause hurt and confusion and
I'm sorry for the families of the people
that had nothing to do with the the
trauma that I had been through and that
I use my platform where you say hurt
people hurt people and I I was hurt I
was frustrated I was frustrated that Gap
hadn't opened stores I was frustrated
that I spent time with a gentleman who I
love love love him his wife his kids
David Simon and to open stores and then
he called Bob Martin that Gap and said
I'm not going to open the stores
and I've just been frustrated I just
want to open my Widow stores and I want
to say that it's wrong to hold an
apology hostage and I gotta let go of
that and free you know free myself of
the trauma and say look I'm just gonna
give it all up to God right now and say
to those families that I heard you know
I really want to give you guys a big hug
and I want to uh I say I'm sorry for
hurting you with my comments and I want
to word it and not a pres and not like a
political way but in a presidential way
which means what I knew a president to
be when I was growing up in a sincere
way you know how people give those kind
of I want to give an apology and you're
like but did you you know what I'm
saying like no it has to be I want to go
to every person's grandmother and
grandfather
and every person's son and daughter aunt
and uncle and give them a hug and say
you know what I've been hurt
and I do want you to talk to your boys I
do want you to talk to the people that
are in power the people who do own the
black voice the people who do own the
black void the vote which a lot of
Jewish business people do and I I want
to be able to sit at the table with the
contracts I want my people to sit at the
table with the contracts I do want all
of this but I'm not going to hold my
apology hostage until I get that I'm
going to start by taking accountability
for my actions and the lack of
sophistication in my wording like I said
I was sleepy and it was taken
and in a way that I didn't mean to me to
be taken it definitely caused some
attention but I don't want the
conversation to go away just because I
came to you guys and said you know I
understand how I hurt you and I'm sorry
for the pain that I've caused and the
confusion that I cause now that is said
right but I don't want the conversation
to go away that we are still in a place
where these contracts are still up my
people are still getting screwed this
has to be opened up and I'm not asking
for a promise but it would be a
beautiful world as as I release the pain
that I've caused and the pain that I
have in me that Grudge that I was
holding that you guys some of you guys
one two of you guys step up and say
let's look at these contracts let's make
it not be a known fact that the music
industry is treacherous let's make
because my kids some of my kids do music
you know I don't want them to step into
a treacherous place I wanted to be
better for them than it was for me so I
wanted to sit down and come together and
really work on that what would that make
sense to you pierce you know what you
ate if you simply said that in your
tweet I don't think there would have
been any problem and I'm very very
pleased actually that we've got to a
place where you felt able to say that
and I think it was sincere but we still
have a problem that's my point I know I
get it I get it but what you've now done
you've now explained the context of the
problem and you also issued a sincere
apology to people who were rightly
offended by the way you phrased what you
said so I think that's a that's a good
place to finish the interview and I I'm
very glad you got there
okay but it's not finished ideas not
finished I understand that there's that
there's still a problem I understand no
one's going to be in any doubt there's a
problem and by the way I'm sure there is
I'm sure a lot of the contracts in the
music business are rigged against people
uh like like artists like yourself I'm
sure of it it's always been the case
from Elvis oh yeah so I I guess would
you would you would you help me and my
people would you help me and my my
athletes I got so many athletes that go
to my school that are like all the guys
that are on down there are headed to the
NBA right could you help me could you
help us make these contracts better for
our people by call calling attention by
just allowing me on your platform right
and let's look at some of the things and
point these things out could could we
work together on absolutely it happened
in the Years very happy we can do that
yeah very happy to do that I think we
should talk more often all right it's
taken a long time to get here I've
thoroughly enjoyed our conversation it's
been two hours it's been free rolling
it's been occasionally challenging but
we've got to a place where I think it's
a good place and I've really enjoyed it
so thank you very much indeedia for
sparing me the time okay
you know you know I'm gonna feel like
I love I I lost my stone I was holding
yeah
yeah but but I but I had to give it up
to God you know what I'm saying like yes
it you know you're gonna be bragging
you're going to be bragging at dinner
tonight like yo I talked to yay no one
could do it no one could do it I did it
and you know
I'm I'm I'm giving you this and I'm
gonna pray that you as a fellow believer
in Christ will help me to expose all the
wrong that's still currently happening
to my people specifically in the
entertainment industry because honestly
I'm very happy to start with I'm very
happy to hold anyone to account who is
behaving improperly honestly and I'm I'm
absolutely certain that that
entertainment business is riddled with
people who try it on and exploit people
and I'll be very happy to help you to
expose that but for now I've got to
leave it yay we've had two hours it's
been remarkable thank you very much for
your time
peace